hey what's going on it's bill byrne it's
time for the monday morning podcast for
monday
july 26 2021 what's going on
how are you
how's it going in your neck of the woods
is everything going all right jesus
christ i hope it is
i hope it is um
you know it's a new variant starts to
settle in we're seeing the numbers are
on the rise and a lot of unvaccinated
people
um i'm actually really enjoying those
news stories now you know i used to used
to bother me
like come on everybody why can't we all
do the same thing so we're all on the
same page man
and now i just realized it doesn't
[ __ ] i don't give a [ __ ]
i don't care it's just like dude you
want to go out there and [ __ ] catch
this [ __ ] and lose your sense of [ __ ]
smell or taste do it man
nobody's going to tell you what to do
man [ __ ] do whatever you want to do i
don't give
a [ __ ] i'll stay home for another year
with my kids i don't give a [ __ ]
you know think i can't turn on a [ __ ]
little goddamn recorder and talk to
myself at [ __ ] seven o'clock in the
morning
because i can't you don't scare me
[ __ ] people who want to do whatever
the [ __ ] you want to do
um yeah there we go
so yeah i don't give a [ __ ] and all
these people you're gonna get vaccinated
they're gonna put a [ __ ] microchip in
you you're already microchipped you got
a [ __ ] goddamn
phone you put in your pocket you won't
walk away from it it's listening to you
the [ __ ] thing listens to you it's
been doing that now christ has been
doing it for years
time i was in a pitch meeting right
what's a pitch meeting bill
you hanging out with a bunch of baseball
player it's a pitch pitch meeting you go
in and you go hey we have an idea for
the show
and they're like oh do you well why
don't you come over and tell us a little
bit about it we're like okay
so you go over there
and you pitch picture shelf so one time
i'm pitching this show right it's me and
this other dude who's like in his 30s
and then the person i'm pitching to is
in their 30s and it's old ass me
so the pitch is going great and
everything so i'm trying to describe the
show
at one point i make a reference to this
old kids show called the banana splits
and the meeting just comes to a
screeching halt because the dude i'm
with and the dude i'm pitching to have
never heard of the show
because it was on like 50 [ __ ] years
ago
so anyway the next day my buddy who i
was pitching with
he goes on his computer or on his phone
and in the side you know the
advertisements on the side there was
there was a a picture of a t-shirt for
the banana splits
the tv show so you're already [ __ ]
microchip hey
siri is arugula
from the spinach family whatever the
[ __ ] you do
that thing's [ __ ] listening to you
these [ __ ] creeps at best buy or
whatever they're [ __ ] watching you
through your smart tv
it's a it's a [ __ ] rap
it's already over you notice anytime
like at this point if something [ __ ]
up happened
if there's not video of it you're like
what what wait
how you know
man in the middle of [ __ ] nowhere
mauled
by a grizzly bear
in [ __ ] you know eastern russia and
there'll be [ __ ] video of it
some park rangers got a goddamn these
[ __ ] [ __ ] went into the woods
and when there was a mother bear
hibernating with her cubs
they went in there and or or something
like that
they went and then they killed this
[ __ ] bear while it was sleeping which
is uh against the rules of hunting
it's not against the rules of starving
but it's against the rules of hunting
you know what i mean but i don't i don't
understand that you know what i mean
it's like all right well i'm gonna go
out and kill a [ __ ] bear
well don't do it while it's sleeping
don't you have enough of advantage
with your fire stick
fire stick you remember that from old
hollywood when they would do movies with
native americans in them
they were played by white people with
rouge on their face
white men come with fire stick yeah they
[ __ ] go up there and they they shoot
this [ __ ] bear while it's sleeping
middle of the woods middle of the
[ __ ] nowhere
other of the [ __ ] nowhere of the
[ __ ] middle of the [ __ ] nowhere
and guess what they got caught there was
video of it
you know what i mean i swear to god dude
if you walked out into the middle of the
[ __ ] amazon
took your dick out and started jerking
off you have like a 50 50 chance
a satellite is going to [ __ ] take
video of it
is it google maps the earth or maps the
earth or whatever
and then all of a sudden your boss is
going to be calling you up right you
have no [ __ ] idea
this is weird i'm down here in [ __ ]
brazil my boss is calling me i hope
everything's all right
do i sound drunk okay hello
why yes yes i am having a good time down
here you know i
as far as i know i still have another
three days down here is everything all
right
what's that
well yeah yeah i mean that was part of
the trip i wanted to see the
amazon forest before it was uh you know
i chopped all the trees down
well you know i did a zipline tour um
i you know we saw the amazon river
well that was yeah that was what
what i did out there yeah yeah i'm
pretty sure that's all i did
well this is i don't understand what
you're getting at
and eventually the guy would be like we
just got a [ __ ] email
that shows someone who looks like you
now this is the middle of
[ __ ] brazil i don't know how many
[ __ ] pasty freckled bald orange men
there are
and you got your goddamn schmeckle out
and you're [ __ ] uh
acting like it owes you money okay it's
already gone viral
uh you're no longer allowed back in the
country so you're not you're no longer
gainfully employed
so i hope you brought some sunblock
because your career is over
as is well you know what they wouldn't
get ready as a citizen
let me look that up if you jerk off in
the rain forest and the satellite
catches you are you allowed back into
the united states
since 9 11
everything went back to 9 11. 9 11 was
the excuse for everything
why are you being hostile uh why are you
being a [ __ ]
drunk with power all right you don't
even know how to fly this thing
um sorry plowing ahead here so
uh yeah you're already [ __ ]
microchipped okay
it's gonna happen the whole thing is
gonna happen
there's nothing you can do about it
because we're not
organized i hate saying that you know
because i don't want to get microchipped
but it's gonna happen
um all right let's get off this [ __ ]
creepy goddamn subject so
everybody out there yeah don't get facts
don't wear max do whatever the [ __ ] you
want breathe all over each other
um and then other people want to get
vaccinated you'll get vaccinated and the
virus evidently will pass through both
of us
and just keep getting stronger because
it's going to take a peek at the [ __ ]
you know what you know what [ __ ] joe
biden needs to do when he wakes up from
his nap
he needs to [ __ ] channel dennis green
rest his soul right football great
football coach
dennis green and he needs to get out
there and just yell at these [ __ ]
virus people just be like the covet
virus
was exactly who we thought it was
and we let it off the hook
just get back into yelling at people
um so evidently it's just gonna keep
getting stronger which is sort of
exciting
sort of an exciting thing where you know
because this
there's this theory now with people who
get vaccinated
who are considered liberals socialists
you know hillary sniffers whatever the
[ __ ] they're called
all right they have now gone from all
the leaves are brown
and the sky is grey to being like you
know what
i hope this [ __ ] virus kills all
these other people
like literally which i gotta be honest
with you
i kind of agree with that but not
because of a [ __ ] liberal standpoint
i'm more like about
you know it's gonna be 130 degrees up
and i'm not even about like trees at
this point i'm about me
because that's what this is all about
it's about you so you know what i'm
going to make it about me
i'm a [ __ ] redhead i've i was a
redhead now i'm a red face
i barely [ __ ] survived
summers when it wasn't [ __ ] up but if
there's gonna be like a hundred and
twenty nine hundred thirty degree days
and then a lot of people gotta go so
i'm hoping uh you know
some of the uh you know if the right
bands go out and tour
the right people are gonna show up
and they're gonna breathe all over each
other it's gonna be [ __ ] wonderful
um and then what's funny
is people on the left are then kind of
like well hey man like
then all all the dumb people will get
killed which i love
all the dumb people will die why why are
they dumb because they don't see the
world the way you do
without your science degree that's
exactly right
and i'm a warrior he he him they
social justice awareness black lives
matter
um in my white neighborhood
um yeah that's gonna kill all the dumb
people
and let's just say it killed everybody
who didn't agree with you
it didn't see the world the way that you
did
and now it's a whole bunch of you
walking around and what do you think's
gonna happen
do you honestly think that everybody's
gonna get along at that point
because we all see everything the same
way it's not going to
because what it is is human beings get
annoyed with each other
we're all so flawed so what would happen
is
within the [ __ ] hey man like
all the liberal people that would still
be alive or the conservative people
whoever ends up being right in this
[ __ ] issue
right i'm gonna lean towards the uh
scientists i'm crazy that way
um within that group of people
they would start to break apart once
again
well he's not like liberal liberal or if
this person's like too liberal
this person's crazy and eventually
that'll happen you know i mean look at
[ __ ]
sports teams they're all wearing the
same uniform they always they all want
to win the game
they all want to win a championship how
many [ __ ] times have you seen it
this player hates that player but you're
on the same team
he's got better hair than i do and you
know after the game we went to
applebee's and the chick i was hitting
on he hit on and then he [ __ ] her
instead of me
why does he always win the game within
the game and then the [ __ ] the whole
thing falls apart so
that's not gonna happen what's gonna
happen hopefully
is you know half the planet will die
and even then we'll still be
overpopulated but it will slow this [ __ ]
down
you know i don't know
maybe the glaciers will come back a
little bit but i'm kind of up for it i'm
up
i'm i'm into misinformation and
uh you know i wasn't dumb with my money
thank god
i didn't go out and buy some [ __ ] you
know
40 bill burr fans can't be ron gold
lemay suits
i didn't do that well ebenezer [ __ ]
freckles
sat on his [ __ ] you know and i didn't
you know it wasn't even like a smart
economic move on my part i just know
what i look like
unlike a lot of these [ __ ] on the
internet
who aren't good looking and people as
people are going you're a goddess you're
gorgeous
yes i i you know
i look in the mirror and i see the
reality of what i see
and i'm like who the [ __ ] ever told you
that you could go outside
all right that's a little harsh um
anyway uh i've been going to the gym
hitting the elliptical cardio burns fat
no
cardio burns calories well guess what
i'm getting [ __ ] i'm
getting in good shape here man yesterday
i got two compliments people saying
you're looking good man you're working
out
i was like oh me teehee hee why yes i am
oh billy balliptical been on that
[ __ ] elliptical for [ __ ] uh
elliptical burr been on that thing for
the whole goddamn month i took yesterday
off
because i was actually kind of [ __ ]
depressed i'm not gonna lie to you
um i did that show at the uh
you know at the will turn had an awesome
time but this just was sort of this
impending feeling that like hey man this
is probably the last indoor live [ __ ]
show we're gonna do for a while
was sort of the vibe i was feeling
and um you know i was just like oh god
not this [ __ ] [ __ ] again
you know just just overall it's just
depressing as you just sit there it's
just like
people just don't work together because
they don't
they don't want the truth they they want
to be right that's it
on both sides if there is really just
two sides
everybody just wants to be right the
[ __ ] mass people want to be right the
non-mass people want to be right
and everybody's dug in you know this is
how you make a [ __ ] bundt cake now
this is how you do it it's just
it's over so
um afterwards i was hanging out you know
smoking a cigar right
i had worn a mask the whole night now
i'm smoking a cigar i'm trying to stay
six feet away from everybody as you
should as you're supposed to
unless you you don't think you should
right and all of a sudden
this woman comes into the fray who's
[ __ ]
hammered hammered like like i respected
the level of drunk she was
it was like that level like just came in
you know like a toddler you know where
toddlers don't wait for people to stop
talking they just start [ __ ] talking
she was doing that [ __ ] right and then
finally like she was so drunk somebody
gave her a chair to sit down it
all right nice enough person but [ __ ]
hammered
and i'm not judging her because you know
god knows i got after it back in the day
i've been that drunk
and uh i was probably even louder
so anyway someone was talking about
the new john mayer album and i was
saying yeah man i heard nothing but good
things i heard it's like one of his best
albums if not his best album
he said yeah he's been describing it as
sad rock it has like an 80s vibe and
sound
and you know i saw the billboard on
sunset and my buddy was saying yeah man
he kind of looked
almost looked like a rick springfield
sort of album cover
and all of this stuff and all this
really cool sort of like uh
sort of theme that he came up with and
then the marketing behind it which i
always find fascinating
as a music lover so he tells the whole
[ __ ] story
and uh it was really fascinating and
when he finishes telling the story
everybody's kind of like huh oh wow
that's cool i'm gonna check out that
album
and then it gets like quiet and then the
drunk lady goes
and then what
there was like a pause and i just
started [ __ ] cracking up laughing
and it just kind of made me remind once
again you know
of being in a pitch meeting and you're
done with the pitch and then they're
like
and then what then what happens with the
show and you're like
uh and then nothing like that that was
the pitch
oh sh you thought there was that that
felt like it wasn't done
and then you know you're not gonna sell
the show if it doesn't feel like it's
[ __ ]
done to them that means they're looking
at it like it's a [ __ ]
undercooked half-baked [ __ ] idea and
guess what your dreams done
you can go back to the chuckle hut buddy
because you ain't getting on tv
[ __ ]
and that's how this business works you
know
unless you know you're a [ __ ] white
woman then you get to be like well
how come you have you you you picked up
the guy
showing you didn't pick up my show and
then they have to pretend like
your idea didn't suck because you have a
vagina
am i exaggerating of course i am but
it's fun
that's what comedy is exaggerating
exaggerating the truth
or what you think is the truth it may be
a lie that you want to be true
right all right let's look up right now
how many people
are going to die
with the new strain of
covet it's like a game show come on big
number come on big number
come on big number all right the delta
variant of course it's called delta my
least favorite [ __ ] airline
jesus christ the [ __ ] the amount of
sky [ __ ] that are on that [ __ ]
airplane
everybody has status like 90 of the
plane boards before first class
i've never understood it i get the
beginning where they're like
mothers you know with kids
uh troops
you know anybody who's deputized i
understand all of that [ __ ]
all right let's get all the people that
control the people
on the [ __ ] plane first you know uh
kevin costner's stunt double
in my bodyguard is he here yeah you can
go on
right anybody with the [ __ ] you know
hey it's [ __ ] red shirt wednesday
who's got a red shirt right the whole
[ __ ] plane gets on
of course it's called delta um
delta airlines is for dumb people it
really is
you know what i mean american airlines
is for [ __ ] old people
like myself slash people who want to
make it great again
and then all those other ones are all
going to go out a bit united
i don't know what they you know i i was
into united until they absorbed
us air and i'm just like jesus christ
you know what i mean
you got to watch who you hang out with
you know if you start hanging out with
the wrong kinds of people you're gonna
end up doing what they were doing so
united i don't know about those guys
all right the effects of a virus
variants uncover now i wonder how many
people are gonna [ __ ] die
death rate prediction
covid 2021 come on big number big number
this week's national ensemble predicts
that the number of newly reopened covert
19 deaths will likely increase over the
next four weeks
with 1200 to 5300 new deaths
likely reported in the week ending
august 14
2021 that's [ __ ] amazing you know
what's crazy about this
morbidly what if i get it and i [ __ ]
die
well he wanted people to die but he
didn't count on it being himself
then he do some trashy uh
true podcast stories of hollywood
podcasting
ain't it a [ __ ] um
all right i gotta do some shout outs
here not shout outs uh
pay my respects to some people here jeff
lebarr
of cinderella um lead guitar so that
amazing band that i saw a couple of
times
so i'm open for ac dc and i saw him on
some um
monsters or something i can't even
[ __ ] remember but
uh i always loved that band
and uh he was just a [ __ ] rock star
killer vibed he looked great he had all
those cool guitars
and um in memory of him i actually
watched cinderella at the peace festival
in moscow
1989 where they came out and did like a
50-minute set i watched the whole thing
last night
and uh i was watching it i was just like
man i just
really miss
people being able to play instruments
i just miss it you know i get when
people play instruments now it's not
going to sound like the music that i
listen to
oh back in my heyday when i had my
orange
in red locks
i just really [ __ ] uh
i really miss that [ __ ] and uh
when i see like a dj i know there has to
be an art form to it
or else anybody with the [ __ ] laptop
would be doing what these people are
drawing the crowds that they're drawing
i should probably try to understand it
more i guess i gotta look at them
more like a composer
you know because then you know they're
still telling a story with what whatever
music they're uh typing however it
[ __ ] works i don't i don't get it
you know what i mean you know you know
i'm a horseback rider
and all of a sudden the car shows up i'm
like where's the horse
how does it go i don't understand that's
not
a horse tell you right now you give me a
horse any day over that [ __ ] thing
can't even go down a goddamn trail
this is called asphalt what the hell is
that
that looks like lava but it's black
right
kind of like that musically but anyway
without trashing the young people and
their drugs and they're fun i really
[ __ ] miss
watching young people that know how to
play [ __ ] guitar and drums and bass
can sing live and all of that [ __ ] and
uh yeah so i watched
cinderella at the moscow peace festival
1989 which was a big deal
because uh back then you know we were
[ __ ] we were like the uh carl
colorado avalanche and the [ __ ]
detroit red wings back in the day in the
late 90s we were like you know
we weren't getting along not saying
we're really getting along now but like
the big thing back then was people in
russia they couldn't get uh
they couldn't get stuff from america
and one of those you know jeans and all
of that [ __ ]
and one of the big [ __ ] things was uh
music so it was a big deal when
gorbachev got in there and he let these
bands come in and play
the fa the crowd was going [ __ ] nuts
it must have been so exciting to go over
there and play
slash i would be nervous like um none of
you guys have drugs on you right
right you're flying over there
uh i would have been terrified um
you know uh fred curry had the [ __ ]
power toms
played the pearl kit and that was a big
deal back then like
with like drums you know
everybody played either uh tama or tama
i never knew how to say that or pearl
right until
the [ __ ] late 80s and then all of a
sudden drum workshop dw
came out and everybody changed and i
remember tommy lee
was always playing pearl and then he
went to he switched over to dw
and then everybody did um
the dude from poison i remember he
switched over
but then all the [ __ ] speed metal
guys all played uh
tama drums and that became like it's
like literally just like
within metal music the subsets of metal
music there was like the gear that you
had to have
and i want to give i think slash was the
guy if not tom kiefer i would say
slasher tom keifer
brought the les paul back because
everybody had the [ __ ] shredder
guitars
i saw a thing one a time backstage with
cinderella and
tom kieffer was showing all of his he's
the lead singer all
also killer guitars was showing all of
his guitars and he was playing vintage
guitars
in the 1980s and he had a 1959 les paul
les paul which i hope he still has
because those things are worth like
[ __ ]
you know 350 half a million bucks last
time i looked
um you know when they say
if you could go back in time you know
would you bet like the super bowl and
[ __ ] like that if you went back
in time to 1959 and you just walked into
a [ __ ] if they had a store
if you just ordered 10 1959 les paul
guitars you would never have to work
again if you sold nine of them
like i don't know i guess you'd still
have to wait for 50 years doing some job
you hated
and then if you went well no
wait how does this scenario work bill do
you have to go back in time with those
buy those 10 guitars and then come back
dude can you imagine that if you
discovered a [ __ ] time machine
and you went back in time and rather
than trying to
uh affect some [ __ ] positively
you know
go back in time and just be like uh mr
lincoln
you might not want to go to that play
tonight you know instead of doing that
[ __ ] you're like you know what i'm gonna
do i'm gonna go back to 1959
buy a bunch of les paul guitars i'm
gonna [ __ ] go back to 1955 or 53 or
whatever and get a mickey mantle rookie
baseball card
and then i'm gonna [ __ ] it you know
i'm gonna buy a bunch of property in the
valley like bob hope did
knowing that eventually they're gonna
build or want to build on it
you just did it to build your portfolio
i always wonder what would happen if you
went back right
like if you went back and you killed
hitler
right you killed all those nazi [ __ ]
right then where does where does america
end up
because it was because of those nazi
[ __ ]
that we ended up rising up in power
afterwards
simply by the fact that we were still
standing
because all of europe was bombed out
except for the countries that remained
neutral like sweden sweden stayed
neutral switzerland stayed neutral just
the fact that they were still a
functioning
country because i'll tell you it's weird
when you go to um
like the netherlands you just see like
everything looks
you know pretty new and i was talking to
them about that guy you guys don't have
a lot of old buildings out here and they
say uh
like the germans
it's like wow so every once in a while
you'll come across when i went to
germany when i'm in berlin
uh there was some old church that i saw
that was still like half
bombed out from world war ii it's
[ __ ] wild
to go over there i don't know what the
hell i'm talking about here uh another
shout out
um uh rest in peace
jackie mason
jackie mason one of the most underrated
[ __ ] comedians of all time
i wish i didn't just swear there jackie
mason one of the most underrated
comedians of all time
because he didn't need to swear i saw
that guy on broadway
um
where the hell was i i was in new york
city i'm trying to remember the name of
the uh
the name of the theater that i saw him
in
i don't remember all i know is this guy
came out
and i was like all right what is this
guy gonna do you know
he's an old guy we'll see we'll see what
this guy's gonna do
you know i didn't have high expectations
i saw him in the late 90s
he was 70 something years old dude this
guy came
out and just absolutely murdered
for an hour murdered then took
a 15-minute intermission and then came
out and did another 45 minutes
just absolutely destroying and i would
say
as far as people from that generation
that i'm really happy that i got to see
that went out and just absolutely killed
it
uh jackie mason
joan rivers and george carlin
i would put on the mount rushmore of uh
not saying there aren't any anybody else
from that generation but just as far as
how long they were at the top of their
game
how much material they wrote and how
long they could be on stage and
absolutely destroy
so i feel very fortunate that i got to
see him
the guy was a rebel he got banned from
the ed
sullivan show um
here it is middle finger incident he
allegedly gave ed sullivan
the finger he denied it this is 1964
so he would have been let's see 1928 30.
he was 36.
okay right as you're hitting your stride
as a comedian euron ed
sullivan who was johnny carson before
johnny carson
um i mean put it this way the beatles
did the ed sullivan show and then
after that they were the [ __ ] beatles
that's how big that show was here in
america right
relax england i'm not saying they
weren't the beatles over there
okay all right on october 18th 1964 in
an appearance on the ed sullivan show
mason allegedly gave host ed sullivan
the finger
on air footage of the incident shows
mason in the middle of doing his
stand-up comedy act
and then looking towards sullivan who
had placed himself directly behind the
camera
camera commenting that sullivan was
signaling him
sullivan was reporting letting mason
know by holding up two fingers
that he only had two minutes left and to
cut his act
short as the program was about to cut
away due to having been
partly preempted by an impromptu speech
by president lyndon b
johnson that the show carried
mason began working his own fingers into
his act
to make fun of the situation oh no and
pointed towards sullivan
with an index finger a thumb but not as
sullivan mistakingly believed his middle
finger
oh sullivan was infuriated by this and
banned mason from future appearances on
the show
canceling mason's six uh six appearance
contract
worth 45 grand and the equivalent of 375
thousand dollars in 2020.
uh mason denied knowingly giving
sullivan the middle finger
he later said that he had not heard of
the middle finger gesture
at that time all right we got to click
on the middle finger gesture
in western culture the finger and middle
finger
is an obscene gesture the jester
communicates
meaning [ __ ] me [ __ ] you it doesn't mean
[ __ ] me means [ __ ] you
shove it up your ass up yours go [ __ ]
yourself it's performed by showing you
know how it's formed
classical error the gesture dates back
to ancient greece oh there goes that
excuse
it was also used in ancient rome
historically it represented the phallus
is that the dick a phallus is a penis
all right how come nobody says that
hey baby you want to see my phallus
sorry in the early 1800s it gained
increasingly recognitions as a sign of
disrespect
and was used by music artists notably
more common among actors celebrities
athletes and politicians
most still viewing the gesture is
obscene the index finger and the ring
finger beside the middle finger in more
contemporary periods
has been likened to represent the testes
well they really got into this all right
let's get back to jackie here
to clear his name mason filed a libel
suit on the grounds that sullivan had
defamed him
at the new york supreme court the court
dismissed most of mason's complaints
money both mason and sullivan appealed
to the new york supreme court
oh now he's suing the guy or he's going
after mccor
which reinstated three additional causes
of actions against sullivan in june
66 mason was nevertheless banned from
the show for a period of time
sullivan asserted that mason was
unpredictable and could not be trusted
because of sullivan's influence he was
branded as
unreliable volatile and obscene and he
failed to get substantial television
work for the next two decades
oh my god mason was you know what he did
the voice of the aardvark on the pink
panther
mason was given a single comeback
appearance on the sullivan television
show
programmed two years later and sullivan
publicly apologized to him
but the damage was done at that time
mason opened his monologue by saying it
is a great thrill and a fantastic
opportunity to see me in person again
mason later appeared on the show five
times
april 23 67 back february 68 november 68
july 69 august 69.
mason later said it took 20 years to
overhap
to overcome what happened in one minute
wow so he kind of got cancelled
you should definitely read about this
guy i mean
absolutely uh an absolute beast
totally original and i feel so lucky
that i got a chance to see him so rest
in peace jackie mason
rest in peace jeff lebar um all right
and with that
it's almost time for the advertising but
i got to give a shout out to your boston
red sox
the most exciting game of the year they
were down four to nothing the yankees
had a no
hitter going which is exciting
right and then all of a sudden the
eighth inning came and the red sox
scored
five count them five runs they shut down
the yankees in the top of the ninth
to win it five to four and that's the
way it was
yesterday at fenway park i gotta get the
mlb
package it's time i just have to get it
uh but i am you know gonna be going on
the road here i don't know i'm gonna get
it
i kind of i was yesterday i was watching
was i watching the uh
white sox and the brewers and
um i don't know i just i really like
baseball
i know it's not the most popular thing
to say but i i [ __ ] like it
um oh i did mention yes i got really
[ __ ] depressed and bummed out
you know just with the fact that all of
this shit's coming back you know
allegedly i have no idea and uh
so yesterday i hung out with a buddy of
mine who's not in show business
we went out we got some barbecue i had a
root beer float and i smoked a cigar and
i felt like a million bucks
i'm going to pay for it in my way and i
think i'm about i'm about a buck 80
right now so um um
i lost you know about nine pounds this
month if i can lose nine pounds next
month i'll be
you know low 170s and then you know lose
a couple more
give myself a little buffer
dude is anything better than a [ __ ]
root beer float oh my god
it's [ __ ] amazing really is what life
is about
all right you know what else life is
about about getting good [ __ ]
humanely source to meet consent to you
butcher box everybody
you know summer is all about savoring
every moment
whether you're hosting a backyard
get-together or an impromptu gathering
butcherbox will help you spend less time
searching for high quality meat
so you have more time for making
memories butcher box delivers humanely
sourced meat
of your choosing right to your doorstep
options like 100 percent
grass-fed and finished beef free-range
organic chicken
humanely raised pork wild caught a
laspin taylor
tails lobster tails wild caught lobster
tails
wild caught alaskan salmon you don't
know what the [ __ ] they're gonna do
and sugar slash nitrate free bacon
each box ships with 9 to 11 pounds of
meat
packed fresh shipped frozen and vacuum
sealed
uh my favorite thing to grill in the
summer i like the burgers man
i'm a burger person uh whether you
customize your box or order a curated
section focus on how you always get your
choice of high quality options
i always go with the uh heritage breed
pork
um the chicken's great
plus i love having it in the freezer you
know
and you're thinking what am i gonna have
for dinner tonight you just pull it out
you thaw it out
you pull out the meat man but now you
know in a very healthy post me too kind
of way
give yourself a vegetable you know you
got your protein you got your vegetables
you drink a bunch of water you wake up
the next day and your stomach's a little
flatter
luckily today's sponsor butcher box
wants to celebrate
uh you this summer right now butcher box
is offering new members two
free lobster tails and two free ribeyes
oh you gotta love a ribeye
in your first box so you can share a
high quality surf and turf meal with
friends
or enjoy it by yourself your sad sack um
the process is simple sign up and choose
your box
and delivery frequency they offer four
curated box option
options and a custom box that lets you
choose your favorite cuts
butcher box ships your order frozen at
the peak
of freshness and packed in an
eco-friendly 100 recyclable box
uh you enjoy high quality meat delivered
to your door and more time for amazing
meals together
butcher box is offering our listeners
two five ounce lobster tails
and two 10 ounce ribeyes for free in
your first box you can only get this
special deal when you sign up for a new
membership
at butcherbox.com burr that's
butcherbox.com for your first
for your free lobster tails and ribeyes
in your first box i mean come on man
all right policy genius everybody you
know
while you're laying layering
on the spf this summer don't forget to
protect your property too
policy genius can help you find ways to
bundle your home and auto insurance and
save on the coverage
why policy changes because policy genius
makes it easy to compare
home and auto insurance in one place
they can help you find a home in auto
coverage similar to what you have now
but at a lower price they've saved
customers an average of 1
250 american dollars per year
over what they were paying for home and
auto insurance their team will handle
the paperwork to set you up
to set up your new policy or switch over
your current one getting started is easy
first head to policygenius.com
and answer a few quick questions about
yourself and your property
then policy genius takes it from there
they'll compare rates from america's top
insurers from progressive to allstate
to find your lowest quotes the policy
genius team can look for ways for you to
save
uh to save you more including bundling
your home and auto policies
if they find a better rate than what
you're paying now they'll switch you
over for free
their top-notch services earn policy
genius thousands of five-star reviews
across
trustpilot and and google head to
policygenius.com to get started right
now
policy genius when it comes to insurance
it's nice
to get it right all right
okay with that let's do some of the uh
some of the inquiries some of the
questions here for this week
um all right einstein correction
oh jesus did i say something wrong about
the crazy-haired son of a [ __ ] there
hey chill bill no more drunk slurper
um in the podcast on the 15th of july
you joked about albert einstein having
invented the atomic bomb
actually he did not oh [ __ ]
shots fired was this tesla again
sorry i had to get that yawn up been
fighting it for 20 minutes he even
warned the us government
about the advances of the german
physicists
you know people what has happened to
like basic grammar here
actually he did not okay you say he
didn't inv
he he joked about albert einstein having
invented the atomic bomb
actually he did not he even
warned the u.s government about the
advances of the german
oh i see what you're saying sorry that
was my fault physicist i hear you saying
he didn't do that and he even did this
well then shouldn't you say he did this
and he even did this
yeah i think i am right he didn't invent
atomic bomb
but he did warn the you you should have
said but instead he even
i swear to god i don't think you guys
are like dumb i just think you voice
text these things
so this is how somebody was talking i
wouldn't notice this but the second it's
written down you're like
that doesn't make sense or maybe i'm
dumb i'll go with the last one
anyway um he warned he even warned the
u.s government about the advances of
german physicists
he regretted it in hindsight as it
spurred the us government
on in their project which ended in the
japanese genocide
um he said in the interview had i know
that the germans would not succeed in
developing an atomic bomb
i would have done nothing all right dude
[ __ ] relax
if you think that we wouldn't have come
up with that thing unless you brought it
up
we we would have all right
because we invented that thing did we
stop at that thing
after after albert died and well well i
guess that's
it albert can't warn us of anything else
you know he went on to [ __ ] nuclear
weapons
anyways just wanted to clarify that and
defend my passed away countrymen
um
country man where the [ __ ] was he from
all right bill just
just just stop you're dumb all right
something positive to change the subject
i think it is underrated what
you did for yourself and your family by
stopping drinking and going to therapy
how aren't you nice after i sat there
and trashed your grammar
if a ginger binger i love that
drinker like you can do it anyone can do
it by the way improve your german accent
no i'm not going you improve your
[ __ ] english accent
i love how everybody around the world
thinks that they can imitate americans
but like you know it's like you go to
france and they don't want to listen to
your french
but when you come over here i have to
listen to your english i will
tusi store it's not z it's the
um it doesn't really give our bad accent
it's due
when you do your hitler bits i don't
give a [ __ ] thanks for cheering up
my cubicle ass and leave einstein alone
and go [ __ ] yourself
um all right i'll try to get better with
the german exit
um i'm just doing who i'm really doing
is
uh what's his face
oh my god from um
from what the [ __ ] the name of the
movie
also known as why i love the bomb it's
one of my favorite movies of all time
and i can't remember
uh the name of it now i'm just not going
to think of it and it'll come up to
me and then the guy peter who played the
pink panther
i have all half information today
in my in my brain it's his
version of the german guy it's who i'm
doing
all right wait a second let me let me
let me i gotta look this up here
why the [ __ ] can i [ __ ] remember
anything anymore
you know i'm not drinking i stopped
using deodorant
you know i don't even use deodorant
anymore and you know what's funny is if
you shower every day you're kind of all
right
i'm not a big sweater turns out i'm not
a big sweater so i had all that [ __ ]
aluminum absorbed into my skin
for all of these [ __ ] years you guys
right now first man
you're talking about liberals and now
you're like some hippie
um all right what is it peter
what why i
love the bomb
dr strangelove that's who it was
dr strangelove and i'm doing peter
seller's impression
of a nazi so take it up with him
um all right space dear billy luna head
you know i totally missed out on this
whole jeff bezos going to
space and that dick-shaped rocket which
you know he did on purpose because
everyone was going to say it was a
phallic symbol anyway so he's like all
right let's give it a [ __ ]
helmet uh lots of people are coming at
jeff bezos for his trip to space the
common complaint is that he spent all
this money going to space and that money
could be used for people who need it
i think this is an uninformed [ __ ]
stance
no really you're not seeing all these
homeless encampments first off the
amount of money it costs to go to space
is one twentieth of the budget
taxpayers hand over to our military
to fund research projects to make better
killing machines
okay but they're just saying he could
have taken that money and given it to
poor people
you're telling me if he didn't use that
money to go to space he would have just
given it to the pentagon
um or you're saying that his tax money
would go towards that maybe that's what
your tax dollars maybe that's what
you're saying
so for starters the people bitching are
actually funding a less productive
venture while screaming blasphemy at the
rich guy
well he also could just write a check
where he could pay his p
the people at amazon better money also
let's just call a hypocrite a [ __ ]
hypocrite if you have amazon packages
coming to your house
maybe don't [ __ ] about what the guy
does with the money you gave him
there right there ladies and gentlemen
is the end of the argument that is a
great [ __ ] point
the amount of people that was [ __ ]
on him that [ __ ] you know
myself included i just said pay your
employees better
the poor people they got to park in the
middle of the street and run to your
house and run back because they don't
have time to do their routes
uh not to mention that this was not a
taxpayer-funded launch
unlike space x which takes in huge
amounts of taxpayer funding to stay
operational
when my tesla driving neighbor stopped
me at the end of my driveway
to [ __ ] about jeff bezos trip as if i
give a [ __ ]
i brought this fact about spacex up
and was immediately met with that's not
true
oh yeah that's what people do you
brought a point that destroys my
argument
i'm not going to take it in i still want
to be right uh it is true bill but truth
is apparently whatever you want it to be
these days
all right stop patting yourself on the
[ __ ] back mr i'm so informed
uh [ __ ] these uninformed pile on
opinions their [ __ ] instagram posts and
tweets are just as bad as the cable news
companies
you've rightfully been bitching about i
you know what you win the argument again
all right i like this guy
you made two [ __ ] tremendous points
you're bitching about a guy and you
[ __ ] buy [ __ ] from his company
and your instagram page is just as
dishonest as those news companies yes
yes they are i was saying that to a
buddy of mine how everybody now
like everybody like knows how to
just take the piece of information that
they need and then spin it
um the hairy leg chicks are really good
at it
uh my boyfriend is cynical
yeah that'll wear you down it's great if
you want to watch a comedian for an hour
[ __ ] on things but after a while you
know you need to go get a root beer
float myself included
maybe i was depressed because i heard my
act on saturday night
um hi bill so i only know about you
because my boyfriend won't stop
stop talking about you and he listens to
you almost every other day
all right did i need to know that you
had [ __ ] you don't watch anything
that i do i get it you're not a fan all
right
i'm here to rant and complain about how
cynical he is
getting lol it's upsetting because
i've been the type of person who is
understanding oh okay let's [ __ ] on your
boyfriend and talk about how great you
are
and gets excited about life i try to
cheer him up whenever he's down
or try to be a lending ear when he needs
to vent
oh but if you're positive and excited
about life yeah he's gonna wear you down
but he seems to have a vent and finds a
problem for almost everything
no matter how much i try to be there for
him
and help it's just getting so exhausting
he just turned 30 and can be so
difficult to deal with
and i'm starting to think that he has
some kind of mood disorder
or anger management issues
all right okay i see where this is going
because i am
i was this guy and that's right around
when it happened right around 30. um
i don't know what to do because it's
hard to move forward with someone who is
constantly complaining and finds a
problem with everything
and seems to only worry about himself
all right the way you describe this guy
you should break up with him i
understand that life has its struggles
but he judges and rants and complains
about every little thing
it's tiring to be around and i don't
know what to do because he's stubborn
and difficult
i try to be patient and understanding as
best that i can to be fair
he's self-aware enough to know that he
can get like this but i'm tired
i have needs to lol all right well you
seem like a [ __ ] happy
cool person with a good sense of humor i
don't know how bad this is
but uh you know it's probably some sort
of childhood issue and some right around
you know when you haven't found your
dream job you're not married you don't
have kids you don't you start to feel
like you're getting behind the herd
um
and you don't quite know what the [ __ ]
wrong with you
because as far as my life went my 20s
and 30s
was all about like [ __ ]
you know taking out my childhood on
other people and lashing out at people
before you know
you get into your late 30s you go all
right well i'm still
sitting in this hole maybe it's
something i'm doing
um i would just tell them just saying
listen you're sucking the life out of me
and i'm young and i'm in my prime which
means if i stay with you
if you continue to be like this i'm
gonna die earlier
um so why don't you [ __ ]
go into therapy try to turn that frown
upside down
or uh i'm gonna [ __ ] leave
you know because i i do have to tell you
this you can't make somebody else happy
you can't they can meet you and be
infatuated with you and go through the
initial stages of love
but then after a while you know they're
gonna kind of be who they are
and um you know
something like that can drag you down to
where they're at
which i would hate
to see that happen to you and i hope i
didn't do
that to anybody back when i was like
that
i'm not saying i'm 100 cured as you can
tell by this podcast
so um what can you do all you can do
in a relationship is communicate to
somebody what they're doing
you know that is affecting you in a
negative way
you can also communicate to them you
know when they're doing something good
too
ladies but you can't fix them
so i would communicate what you're
saying to me to him
see what he does with the information
and if it's not working for you i would
leave
because if he's already acting like a
[ __ ] crabby old man
at 80 i mean i'm sorry at 30 what's
going to happen when he's 80.
all right cnn and fox news experience uh
dear billy balloon breast
i was listening to your bit on the
podcast for the 19th time
about cnn and fox and wanted to share my
personal experience
as just how messed up the situation is
oh i love hearing from people that used
to work for these [ __ ] companies
in 2016 i was 17 years old
oh this is just going to be one okay and
was watching tv with my mom stepdad and
sister
after dinner we were watching their
favorite [ __ ] show news channel of
choice
cnn side note i had just enlisted into
the army and was set to leave for basic
training that summer
anyways i can't recall exactly what the
segment was covering but it had
something to do with fear-mongering
about the conflict in the middle east
because my stepdad
knows that i don't feed mindlessly off
the [ __ ] that's cnn and fox news
uh i am of course on the outside of the
clique so he likes to use things like
that to start up a fight
he questioned me about the topic but to
him the only correct answer is whatever
[ __ ] the almighty cnn spews
into their followers uh one thing led to
another before the night was over he
told me in front of my mother and sister
that i would inevitably die in the
middle east because i don't believe in
what cnn spews
jesus christ talk about trying to win
the argument at all costs
after he realized that i wasn't going to
engage in his stupid pointless argument
he threw a punch and i had no choice but
to fight back
uh anyway what started as a stupid
argument about our desired news sources
turned into me getting kicked out of my
house at 17 years old
i just wanted to give my story about how
these news sources
uh went from being important sources of
information to a sort of
team or country of their own where if
you're not 100
with them you are against them and
deemed an enemy of the group of
followers they have
the modern era of news is toxic and
needs drastic change yeah
not to say that back in the day you know
they were always spending it
but it wasn't to the level that you knew
who the broadcaster voted for
[Music]
which is [ __ ] insane i mean back in
the day
you thought wrestling was real and you
didn't know who the [ __ ] broadcaster
voted for
that was it um anyway sorry to ramble
but anyway i love the podcast and just
to end up
and hope to see you at one of your
upcoming dates thanks and go [ __ ]
yourself
yeah you know it's the pendulum swings
back and forth
you know i remember back in the day when
we were starting all this
going to war stuff you couldn't sit
there and question like are we really
going over there for these people's
freedom
you know am i really supposed to believe
that the way you've treated
the government has treated [ __ ]
veterans of all wars the way that
they've treated
poor people people who aren't white and
all of this [ __ ] in this
country the way they've treated their
own citizens i'm supposed to believe
that you care about these people on the
other side of the planet
who are sitting on all of this oil and
the oil is not a factor and i remember
back then
if you [ __ ] suggested that that meant
that you didn't support the troops which
is so insane
why wouldn't you support your own
[ __ ] home team
and that uh you know
the whole thing is so [ __ ] the same
[ __ ] people that if you said hey man
i think we're going over there for oil
they're like america love it or leave it
you know and now the vaccine comes out
now they're like i don't trust the
government
and now why can't i be hey america love
it or leave it
they're saying get the vaccine you're
not getting the vaccine you don't
support the troops right
so it's just what it really comes down
to is most people they're just [ __ ]
selfish [ __ ]
that's all it is you know and i'm not
saying i'm not one
uh well you know we got a lot of work to
do everybody
we got a lot of work to do and i think
the internet was a bad idea
overall it was a bad idea
uh we're probably too dumb to be talking
to one another
i don't you know what i don't have any
[ __ ] uh
i have no solutions just like cnn and
fox where they just scare the [ __ ] out
of you with absolutely
no solutions so i actually i do have a
solution what i try to be is i try to
[ __ ]
walk out into the world hopefully be in
a good mood
and don't drag anybody down with my own
[ __ ] [ __ ]
it's the best that i can do and then i
try to help out younger people
you know i think that that's what older
people should be doing
rather than telling them that their
music is no good [ __ ] i did that at the
beginning of my
podcast all right i'm a work in progress
okay this this is the podcast
everybody and uh
you know what i have really learned i've
really learned in life is that [ __ ]
since becoming a dad like how my level
of happiness has shifted like what
makes me happy now like it used to be
like you know
i'm a [ __ ] you know i'm gonna i'm
gonna [ __ ]
sell this amount of tickets and i'm
gonna have this [ __ ] kind of car in
this big
house and [ __ ] and all this [ __ ] i
have now now that i have kids
you know what [ __ ] makes me happy and
excited is if i have a full box of
bisquick
and enough syrup in the cupboard i know
that that can get me to
12 noon and i get it you can get to the
first [ __ ] nap and everybody's gonna
be happy
all right not saying i make [ __ ]
pancakes and waffles every day but if
the kids come downstairs
and they're in a bad mood and i need to
switch the culture in the locker room
dude you [ __ ] turn on the waffle
griddle
they they [ __ ] light up they light up
you make them the waffles
you get them going you have a couple of
waffles everybody's full of syrup
a little sugar rush yeah baby right
then around 10 everybody needs to take a
nap you know everybody [ __ ] chills up
telling you it's a good [ __ ] thing
see if you can take that little waffle
philosophy
out into your life today then i feel
like this podcast was worth it sorry
um all right that's the podcast
everybody i hope my [ __ ] thing didn't
die again
okay good it didn't um that's it
stop watching these [ __ ] news
channels stop
you know you know i'm not saying all
everything that they say is you know you
know what i i
actually do now as i bring my i bring my
thermos
with water from home out to my show so
i've i've used one water bottle
in the last uh like three months
all right that's my little [ __ ]
nipping at the heels of global warming
and guess what it rained out here in l.a
last night which is [ __ ] great
it's fantastic all right i gotta go make
some waffles i'll see you guys later
uh go [ __ ] yourselves have a great
couple of days and i'll check in on you
on thursday